whether I'm a screenwriter or some other
form of creative I think one of the key
disciplines is to understand the
discipline is key and that is to say
when you when you you you should find
out what works best for you are you a
morning person are you a late night
writer I'm I'm not creative late at
night I like being up but I'm not create
I write like a fiend why when I have
that early morning coffee because all
night has been percolating for me that's
not true for everybody but if that's who
you are
then make damn certain you've gone to
bed at a reasonable hour and then you're
up and you've done gotten your stuff
done and now at 6:00 in the morning or
7:00 in the morning or whatever is you
set aside and you turn your phone off
and you have absolutely sort of put
these pros soundproof walls around you
literally and figuratively so that you
have two to three hours of intensely
productive time on a consistent daily
basis if you do that because it's a game
of inches and if you do that instead of
being the person who's laboring over a
script and rewriting it for years and
you know non-stop or you're doing a lot
of first drafts and you're on your 12th
script this year those are not the
indicators of success but if you're
someone who's got that kind of
discipline and you say how much can i
how much can I improve this we know that
rewriting is writing but up to a point
you know so how many drafts you know if
I can do this every day and then I set
it aside move on to the next one I may
come back to that with proper
inspiration but if you do that what you
can accomplish in a short one year
period will put to shame most people who
don't have that discipline who don't
know themselves and give themselves a
framework to be productive
you